so obviously naval had a huge impact on
you just as he has
you know many many people and i think
part of the attraction uh
for people to him is it's not just
business advice
right it's kind of this idea of there's
business advice there's life advice
there's
uh kind of um i don't know self
evaluation advice there's happiness like
there's all these elements to it
um at some point you decide that you're
going to uh
take all this information you're gonna
synthesize it and distill it down and
you're gonna write a book
uh the book is titled the almanac of
naval ravicon a guide to wealth and
happiness
uh is navalmanak is that a
official title as well or is that a uh
easy
easier to remember for people that's
that's my that's my nickname for it you
can't go around saying almanac of naval
rav account all day every day that's
just it's too much it's a long domain
you know so uh so i just kind of
shorthand it to navalmanak
and you know people either get it or
they don't but i'm cool with that
i love that um all right so let's talk
just about uh at what point do you
actually decide hey i'm going to write a
book
uh was it actually the original idea to
do a book
and then kind of let's go through your
process uh because you took a lot of
information and got it down
to uh to something that's pretty
compelling yeah for sure so
i started um started kind of in a
whirlwind
it was you know i thought of a pun one
night this the original title for this
book was the book of navalig
um and i i had this tiny little like
um it was right after uh neval did the
interview with shane parish on the
knowledge project
it was amazing and it's been downloaded
millions of times it's an
incredible interview um and there was so
much in that that was kind of like then
it just really struck me in the face it
was like this is so
good this is all kind of timeless book
worthy wisdom
um that i want more people to kind of
make it easier for them to receive
so i tweeted out uh if i made the book
of novalej compiling some transcripts
and some tweets
like would you guys be into that you
know and i i didn't have a huge
following this was probably you know 10
000 people or whatever
and i you know this is 10 o'clock at
night i tweeted that out went to bed i
woke up and neval had retweeted it and 5
000 people
replied to this poll and we're like hell
yeah we want that like
here we go um and so it was kind of
instant
like public commitment instant
validation
instant um oh my god i have to do this
and there's no way out like the knew i'm
letting down
naval and he was kind of very generous
to say immediately like happy to provide
you with anything you want
you know do you need an archive of
tweets what do you what do you need to
make this a great project
and i don't know um what made him
trust a stranger from the internet to
say like yeah go ahead and write a book
about me
based on the stuff that's already out
there um
but it was uh it felt like a
great project to take on i was really
excited to kind of do this and
immediately people started kind of
checking in on the project and dming me
and saying like
hey when's this going to be ready when's
this gonna be ready um three months in i
had like collected this huge pile of
stuff i had
you know this back catalog of his tweets
just 20 000 tweets and a giant
spreadsheet
and you know just building this list of
sources that's going and going and going
and the more you find
the more you're like oh my god there's
so much gold here especially
kind of the deeper you go back and then
you start categorizing things and so i
would build kind of
um i went through the tweets first and
it was really interesting to see
10 years of twitter history because how
people use twitter has changed so much
and you can see like
almost layers of sediment right that
never was starting venture hacks and
angelus there's a lot of
startup um kind of investing content and
here's how to use it and iterating
through content
and early product and then kind of
building hype around it and then it was
a little bit more about
how to operate a startup who's building
a team he was hiring
and there was more about investing and
as angelus became more and more
successful and kind of independent
you see him kind of shift towards how to
live a good life
like about philosophy share more of the
principles around what he did
to build angel list um it's really you
see this you know pattern in
a lot of biographies and things that you
read of people who kind of change their
focus overlapping even you know farnam
street started out very very like
business investing focused and kind of
transitioned you know
more into this is how you live a good
life this is how you build strong
relationships this is how you you know
find peace um and it's i think a journey
that we are all kind of on and one of
the things i like about
the final product of this book is that
there is something for absolutely
everyone no matter where they kind of
are in that journey
you know 21 year old might be like
really hungry and just hit that help
with that wealth section you know like
over and over and over and over again
um but somebody who's kind of later in
their life might find one or two
principles from the wealth section that
they want to apply but really
you know use the happiness section as a
touchstone to kind of
um keep themselves reminded of more of
that because that's where their focus is
to be more present to be with their
family something like that
so this book took you a pretty long time
to write
uh and mainly it was it sounds like a
lot of uh going through all the material
that was there right it was almost like
it was there you had to find the stuff
and
categorize it how much of this book is
uh things that were already out there
versus um you know either interviews
with naval or elsewhere and i'm cheating
because i know the answer
but uh kind of talk through you know
your reliance on neval
or people close to the wall versus just
stuff out that was available in public
domain
yeah that's um a thing that i i
struggled with actually because naval
was was
willing to contribute interviews and
things like that um
but one of the constraints i put on
myself was this has to be
entirely built from publicly available
material like i wanted that to be
a piece of the book that anyone could
have done this or could have found all
of these i think it like kind of makes
it a very interesting thing i tried to
do
i did no editorializing like there's not
an original word from me
in this book past the author's note like
i wrote the author's note every other
word
as close as i could possibly get it
edited for readability
is is from naval in his own words um
and it was it was really a lot more like
doing a
jigsaw puzzle than it was writing you
know there's
there's so many times i was like i wish
i could just edit this sentence i wish i
could just clarify like i wanted
i want to write here i wanted to change
the words um
but you can't alter the piece you just
have to find the right place for it
and uh we were kind of figuring out what
the right
exact threat is like all of the right
pieces are here you can build an amazing
kind of reading experience
and so much of this comes from
interviews the body of the text comes
from interviews for the most part
that it feels very kind of narrative
one-to-one it's almost like a dialogue
you know it's it's almost feels kind of
like the courage to be disliked or
um you know some of those other kind of
dialogue books that like pull you
through it's very casually written
it's not super structured but i wanted
to give enough categorization so that
you could really easily
reference it go back for specific ideas
you know check in on things
um and use it kind of over and over
again because
you can really power through it in a
first read um but but also like once
those seeds are planted you're going to
want to keep coming back and get
refreshed on the ideas and reapply them
so
uh this past weekend uh i now they
ordered the hardcover book which
everyone should go do and we'll get to
that in a second uh
but also i downloaded the pdf and i
started reading i was telling you that
uh i probably i don't know 80 85 of the
way through and i basically did it in
almost one sitting
uh and what's crazy is i've pretty much
heard almost all the interviews i've
seen the tweets like
you know there's plenty of stuff in
there that i hadn't seen before but for
the most part uh you know
the general things or the meat of it i
had already consumed and it still was
incredibly valuable and i think that's
like a very interesting
uh component maybe talk a little bit
about kind of how you
thought about using the public
information right so there's plenty of
people obviously when the vault is a
podcast or those tweets
that have already consumed this stuff
yet there's still some value here and
kind of writing it down the way you did
and to talk
about how you thought of like the value
for the reader and what they'll get out
of this one uh when they consume the
book
yeah i think it's a totally different
experience to kind of consume
a series of podcasts than it is to go
really deep on one specific topic you
know this was kind of
um this is the thesis of evergreen two
right like you can read one article
a week about network effects and one
article a week about value capture but
unless you
are actually like intensely studying one
topic and mapping things to each other
and kind of
put it all on the table in front of you
it's really hard to see the big picture
and see
how well the concepts relate so you know
you've seen tweets about from naval
about
finding leverage or about how to use
leverage
but until you read you know 10 pages
about leverage this is every example
that he's ever used
that is every specific kind of tool of
leverage or every
uh you know it starts with a
categorization and it goes into how to
actually apply it and then it goes into
kind of examples like the real estate
industry
or contractors about how to apply
leverage to your own business
that you really start to kind of fully
kind of picture the idea and figure out
how you start seeing that pattern now in
real life so it's
you know the definement idea of like
learning the name of something versus
really like learning the system of it
my goal here was to provide so much
context on the key ideas
and so much depth and so much clarity
that we really kind of
showed people the whole system showed
people the whole concept in a way that
really
stuck with you much more than being like
oh yeah leverage is important i get it
and i kind of know what leverage is but
but you're still not unless you're
seeing it in everyday life and
understanding
how people are building businesses with
leverage or with accountability or with
specific knowledge
then you don't really own that idea and
it's not really going to change
you know your life or your trajectory
enough so
getting that really high bar of
understanding is important to me and i
think
is what kind of separates this from some
of the more casual kind of like
dabbling in these ideas is really easy
to do on social media or podcast